la liberté qui capitule et le pouvoir
qui se dégrade n'obtient point merci de
ses ennemis ces chateaubriands qu'il a
dit
ainsi qu'on vous l'a dit je pense
je souhaite qu'on mette un peu d'ordre
dans cette conférence de presse et que
par conséquent on séries des questions
et je vous propose que nous passions
d'abord dans le domaine économique et
social puis dans la politique pure si
Joseph il appelait et enfin la politique
extérieure alors passons d'abord aux
questions dans l'ordre économique et
social
monsieur le Président de la République
dans votre discours de Strasbourg vous
avez suggéré que la France double sa
production industrielle dans la décennie
70 ceci implique à l'évidence un taux
d'expansion légèrement supérieur à celui
actuellement suivi et des méthodes de
financement qui font défaut à l'heure
actuelle doit-on en conclure que vous
préconisez un changement de politique
économique et financière
je n'ai pas employé certainement
l'expression décennie j'ai dû dire dans
les 10 prochaines années
comme ça tout le monde m'a compris
je pense en effet que il faut doubler
notre production industrielle en disant
je ne suis pas sûr
que cela représente une accélération de
ce qui s'est passé au cours des années
69 ou 70 ou je pense bien que la
production industrielle a dû en volume
augmenter de l'ordre de 7 ou environ 7%
par an sur 10 ans on arrive à peu près
au doublement ça sera peut-être en
disant et demi je ne préconise pas un
changement de politique je dis
simplement que notre effort
fondamental doit être porté sur
l'industrialisation sur le développement
de l'industrie que par conséquent nous
devons tout faire pour essayer de mettre
le plus possible des capitaux dans nos
disposons par l'épargne et par le
développement des entreprises dans
l'industrialisation et dans son
développement cela comporte aussi
l'acceptation de capitaux étrangers
l'introduction de sociétés étrangères en
France dès lors qu'elle nous apporte
quelque chose qu'elle nous enrichissent
donc je ne préconise nullement un
changement de politique disons
simplement que je suis pour le maintien
accentuer d'une certaine politique
dans la République pierre Charpy Paris
presse vous avez parlé à Strasbourg
d'une réorganisation nouvelle de
l'entreprise d'une modification de ces
structures qu'elles sont dans ce domaine
vos intentions ou peut-être votre projet
je ne crois pas qu'il appartiennent à
l'État
d'imposer des modifications de
structures dans les entreprises beaucoup
a déjà été fait j'ai cité par exemple
les comités d'entreprise et je lis ici
ou là mais c'est une vieille histoire
ils ont fait la preuve de leur
impuissance d'abord je ne crois pas que
ce soit tellement vrai et en tout cas
rien ne les empêche de se consacrer à ce
qui est une leur vocation principale
c'est-à-dire proprement parler la
participation active des représentants
des travailleurs à la marche de
l'entreprise
mais je pense plus encore qu'à l'action
de l'État à la réorganisation des
structures internes des entreprises
de très nombreux chefs d'entreprise en
France ont déjà su associer leur cadre
leurs employés leurs ouvriers à la
marche de leur affaire soit en leur
donnant un peu plus la parole dans les
conseils d'administration ou les
représentants des comités d'entreprise
siègent et ou trop souvent on considère
que leur présence est purement
symbolique soit dans l'organisation même
du travail dans les affaires et sur ce
point il y a beaucoup à faire en prenant
modèle sur les entreprises les plus
avancées aux États-Unis où l'on a
considérablement déconcentrer les
responsabilités ou les nouvelles
méthodes d'organisation consiste à faire
descendre jusqu'au niveau de l'atelier
et quelquefois jusqu'au niveau de la
machine la possibilité de la décision
tout cela doit se faire beaucoup plus
par la discussion entre les travailleurs
et leurs employeurs que par la voie
autoritaire de l'État je crois pour ma
part à la procédure de consultation et
de concertation
je crois aux conventions collectives et
je crois aux accords directs entre les
intérêts mais naturellement l'État peut
jouer un rôle d'incitateur et doit jouer
un rôle d'incitateur nous avons fait des
progrès nous sommes très loin encore
d'une situation idéale mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de patrons se
rendent compte eux-mêmes que l'époque du
patron du droit divin est révolue
Gabriel Farcas François monsieur le
Président votre gouvernement est en
train de préparer le budget de 1971
celui de 1970 est essentiel tourné assez
largement vers le passé croyez-vous
pouvoir parvenir à un budget plus ouvert
plus largement tourné vers l'avenir
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un budget tourné
vers le passé qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un
budget tourné vers l'avenir
un budget est en effet obligatoirement
tourner vers le passé dans la mesure où
ce que l'on appelle les dépenses
acquises en représentent l'essentiel je
veux dire par là obligatoirement un
budget commence par reconduire tout ce
qui a été décidé précédemment c'est
ainsi que tous les traitements de
fonctionnaires sont évidemment
reconduits représentent une part
importante du budget de la Nation nous
ne pouvons pas éviter cela et je ne
pense pas en tout cas que les
fonctionnaires seraient satisfaits qu'on
supprime leur traitement du budget sous
prétexte de se tourner vers l'avenir
il ne faut pas croire que l'avenir soit
dans ses 10%, cela veut dire d'abord
qu'on lui renouvelle les mêmes
possibilités budgétaires d'équipements
qu'il avait précédemment et qui dans la
mesure où il s'agit d'équipement nouveau
sont déjà des dépenses nouvelles et sont
tournées vers l'avenir et l'augmentation
en pourcentage n'est pas la
ne mesure ne permet pas de mesurer ce
qu'il y a de nouveau dans un budget ceci
étant dit je le reconnais monsieur
Farkas il n'y a rien de plus ingrat que
de faire un budget et plus de et plus
désespérant même pour le Premier
ministre en particulier et pour le
ministre d'économie et des Finances
parce qu'on s'aperçoit que les
ressources d'un pays ne sont pas
illimités qu'en fin de compte on ne peut
dépenser que l'argent que l'on a
c'est-à-dire celui qu'on demande aux
contribuable et que dès lors on est
limité dans ces espérances parce qu'on
est limité dans ses moyens
monsieur
yetan
monsieur le Président c'est le premier
juillet que le programme de
stabilisation aurait dû arriver à son
terme la liberté d'échanges est une loi
fondamentale du marché commun à quand
donc le rétablissement de la liberté
d'échange en France
nous n'avons pas parlé de programme de
stabilisation
nous avons parlé de plan de redressement
effectivement il y a un an
ou à peu près un an
que nous trouvons devant une situation
monétaire économique financière donnée
le gouvernement a été appelé à prendre
un certain nombre de mesures dans la
plus importante est évidemment la
dévaluation
je crois pouvoir dire aujourd'hui que
cette dévaluation a été réussie
et elle a été réussie dans des
conditions particulièrement difficiles
puisqu'elle a été réussie dans un climat
international de surchauffe ou en tout
cas d'expansion alors que chacun sait
que ce qui favorise les dévaluations
c'est au contraire un climat de
récession
cette évaluation a été réussie et nous
avons hier même achevé
de rembourser toutes nos dettes à court
terme que ce soit à l'étranger sous la
forme de soi ou autre que ce soit
vis-à-vis des banques françaises et nous
allons même annoncer que nous
renonçons à imposer aux banques
françaises le dépôt de leur devise au
fond de stabilisation des champs à
l'heure actuelle la France n'a plus de
dettes à l'exception des
985 millions de dollars qu'elle a
emprunté comme ces son droit son quota
au Fond
Monétaire International notre situation
est donc tout à fait satisfaisante le
front des nullement discuté sur les
places étrangères néanmoins nous ne
croyons pas que le moment soit encore
venu de supprimer le contrôle des
changes
nous ne le croyons pas parce que
l'expérience nous a prouvé qu'à le
supprimer trop tôt on risquait d'être
amené à le rétablir qu'il n'y avait rien
de plus fâcheux et aussi parce que la
situation monétaire internationale ne
nous donne pas toute garantie à ce sujet
mais j'espère que dans les prochains
mois il nous sera permis de franchir de
nouvelles étapes et finalement d'abolir
complètement le contrôle des changes je
l'espère et je dirais même je le crois
beau frère Agence France Presse monsieur
le Président et une information qui
vient de paraître fait état de
rationalisation de la production aux
usines berliées dans le cadre de
l'accord Citroën Fiat et de compression
des effectifs pouvez-vous nous dire dans
l'état actuel de l'étude du dossier par
le gouvernement qu'elle serait les
perspectives à votre avis
je me refuse monsieur à parler de
questions particulières et pour des
raisons que chacun doit comprendre
les berliés fait partie de l'ensemble de
toute l'industrie automobile française
une affaire peut connaître un moment
donné plus ou moins de prospérité plus
ou moins de difficultés de toute manière
l'entreprise Berliet une entreprise trop
importante pour que les tasses des
intérêts de son sort mais son sort ne me
paraît pas menacé et quand on
négociations qui peuvent exister avec
Fiat ou avec d'autres sociétés je me
refuse à en parler publiquement
monsieur le Président Jean-Claude vajou
le thème de la nouvelle société revient
souvent dans les discours du premier
ministre les observateurs ont remarqué
que vous n'avez jamais prononcé quant à
vous l'expression de nouvelles sociétés
doit-on conclure que cette
omission est volontaire ou simplement
fortuite
l'expression n'étant pas de moi je ne
vois pas pourquoi je l'emploierai
n'est-ce pas mais ça ne veut pas dire
que je sois en désaccord avec le sur le
fond avec le Premier ministre pas plus
dans ce domaine que dans d'autres en
tout cas
s'il y a une nuance
je dirais peut-être
cela tient à ma formation
ou encore à ma fonction
que j'attache
plus d'importance à l'homme qu'à la
société et à la place de l'homme dans la
société qu'à la forme même de la société
j'amboissonade l'expansion il y a
quelques mois vous aviez demandé à la
ménagère française de s'abstenir de
renouveler sa machine à laver elle l'a
fait peut-être n'est-ce pas seulement
parce qu'elle nous a écouté que lui
dites-vous aujourd'hui
je crois que nous avons aidé la ménagère
française
a s'abstenir d'acheter une machine à
laver en rendant les conditions du
crédit plus difficile
depuis ce temps-là un certain nombre de
mesures ont été prises en sens inverse
à travers cette machine à laver
symbolique vous posez monsieur le
problème de la consommation
alors actuelle en effet si je prends
l'économie française je dirais que
globalement elle est en parfaite santé
elle est très active
ça ne veut pas dire bien entendu qu'il
n'y a pas des branches ou la situation
est moins brillante que dans d'autres je
parle globalement
je dirais ensuite toujours en gros
que les industries de bien équipement
sont non seulement en pleine activité
mais même dans une certaine mesure
encore un état de surchauffe
et que les industries qui produisent des
biennes consommations
sont certainement sinon en
ralentissement tout au moins sur un
palier
il est donc possible que dans les
prochaines semaines ou les prochains
mois nous soyons amenés à prendre des
mesures pour
favoriser
ses industries c'est-à-dire pour inciter
à la consommation et qu'à ce moment-là
je demande au ménagères françaises et je
leur dis c'est le moment pour vous
d'acheter des machines à laver c'est
possible
je crois que si nous devons le faire il
faudra le faire avec précaution et aussi
le faire assez tôt essayez de prévoir ce
qui est toujours vous le savez en
matière économique difficile
il y a d'ailleurs un mystère
le pouvoir d'achat en France au cours de
l'année écoulée à certainement augmenté
de façon très sensible
la hausse des salaires le démontre et
certes la hausse des prix et là
importantes parfois trop importante à
nos yeux mais la différence est tout de
même sensible il y a donc augmentation
du pouvoir d'achat et il n'y a pas
augmentation de la consommation
c'est donc que pour des raisons diverses
les Français et les Français à l'heure
actuelle
sont tournés davantage vers l'épargne et
vers la prudence plutôt que vers la
dépense
jusqu'ici nous nous en sommes félicités
parce que ça évitait certainement la
hausse des prix de devenir excessive et
ça a permis à l'économie française et en
particulier à l'économie aux industries
d'équipements de se développer davantage
il est possible que vienne l'heure d'un
changement je peux vous dire que je suis
ces questions avec le plus grand soin
que je ne suis pas le seul le premier
ministre les ministres d'économie et des
Finances aussi je m'en entretenais
d'ailleurs encore hier avec Monsieur
Giscard d'Estaing et il est possible que
nous soyons amenés dans les prochains
mois à l'automne notamment de prendre un
certain nombre de mesures mais pour
l'instant nous ne pensons pas que la
situation soit telle qu'il faille
intervenir
la vernait Le Figaro vous le
gouvernement et vous essayez de faire de
la France une zone de prix modérée et
d'autre part de poursuivre une politique
d'expansion
dans cette conjoncture qu'est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il est le plus dangereux
une récession venant de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique ou bien au contraire une
inflation persistante
vous m'excuserez monsieur Vernet si je
vous dis que je trouve votre question
est un petit peu obscure plutôt qui me
semble qu'il y a deux questions en une
si vous voulez me faire demander me
demander si je considère la récession
comme plus dangereuse que l'inflation
ou l'inverse
je vous dirai simplement ceci
la récession est un mâle
l'inflation en étonnante je ne sais pas
quel est le pire mais je suis sûr que la
France ne supporte pas la récession
si vous voulez me parler
des conséquences
que peut avoir l'économie américaine sur
l'économie européenne et en particulier
sur l'économie française
je vous dirai qu'en effet c'est très
important que l'inflation ou la
récession américaine ne peut pas ne pas
avoir une influence sur la situation
française et c'est pourquoi je suis de
près également la situation de
l'économie américaine
de ce point de vue là j'ai noté
que pour la première fois c'est
récemment la balance commerciale
américaine c'est sensiblement amélioré
au premier trimestre
la situation économique américaine était
une situation de légère récession
d'après ce que je crois savoir les
statistiques qui vont être publiées
indiquent au second trimestre l'activité
a repris
d'ailleurs l'administration américaine
prend à l'heure actuelle des mesures
pour atténuer les effets des mesures qui
avaient été prises par l'administration
de Johnson est maintenu par Monsieur
Nixon pour freiner l'inflation pour
toutes ces raisons j'ai l'impression
mais ce n'est qu'une impression que nous
n'aurons pas venant d'outre-Atlantique
une influence de récession
peut-être même pourrions-nous plutôt
craindre que ce soit une influence
inflationniste
monsieur
grappa pardon
je vous en prie Lucille augeron le
peuple Bruxelles monsieur le Président
dans une tribune sur une rate dans une
radio périphérique à propos du rapport
de la Cour des comptes il a été dit et
j'en étais surprise que les seuls
sanctions prises contre les
fonctionnaires responsables étaient des
sanctions administratives consistant
généralement en mutation lesquelles
correspondent parfois à un avancement je
voudrais savoir si ce sont les seules
mesures que compte prendre le
gouvernement pour empêcher le retour de
ses anomalies
je suis heureux madame que la Belgique
se préoccupe
des sanctions que nous pouvons être
amenées à prendre contre les
fonctionnaires français c'est la preuve
des lias étroits qui unissent nos deux
pays
je vous propose une chose c'est que
chaque fois que le gouvernement belge
sanctionnera un fonctionnaire belge il
veut bien me le faire savoir pour que
j'essaie de maintenir la parité
Pierre Legrand Crugey l'agence
agrapresse monsieur le Président
l'exemple récent de Nancy nous a prouvé
qu'on pouvait mobiliser l'opinion pour
l'équipement d'une grande métropole pour
l'agriculture c'est généralement
beaucoup plus difficile sinon l'inverse
or avec son environnement rural elle
intéresse directement un Français sur
trois ou moins vous avez dit à
Strasbourg que l'agriculture devait
contribuer à créer une puissance
économique française comptez-vous
engager votre autorité pour que les
agriculteurs et les ruraux puissent être
associés à un grand dessin dans
l'ensemble de l'économie française
le grand dessin des agriculteurs c'est
de nous donner une agriculture puissante
et prospère
il l'ENT entrepris grâce au ciel ils ont
toujours eu mon soutien et ils l'auront
toujours
et
du singe être le seul même à l'échelle
européenne je soutiendrai que
l'agriculture et pour la France une
richesse fondamentale de même que je
soutiensdrais que l'exploitation
familiale doit rester la base de notre
agriculture dans la plus grande partie
de notre territoire voilà ma conviction
et par conséquent
j'espère que vous aurez satisfaction et
que l'opinion
des agriculteurs sera rassuré au moins
en ce qui concerne la pensée du chef de
l'État
on en sort leur monsieur le Président
vous avez à plusieurs reprises exprimez
votre sollicitude à l'égard des
rapatriés d'Algérie or le Parlement
vient de voter une loi d'indemnisation
qui ne semble pas satisfaire les
intéressés
pourrais-je vous demander monsieur le
Président ce que vous pensez de cette
loi
monsieur je n'ai jamais vu une loi qui
satisface les intéressés
lorsque je
me suis présenté au suffrage du peuple
français
j'ai de moi-même
soulevé ce problème des rapatriés
j'ai d'ailleurs rencontré un certain
nombre de leurs représentants
et j'ai écrit je crois je leur ai écrit
que mon intention était de faire voter
une loi
qui prévoierait un mécanisme
d'indemnisation
mécanisme d'indemnisation qui devrait
s'adresser par priorité au plus humble
au plus pauvres au plus modeste et
j'indiquais
que il me paraissait possible
que la collectivité nationale consentie
pour cette indemnisation
un sacrifice annuel de 500 millions
500 millions c'est-à-dire bien entendu
50 milliards d'anciens francs
c'est exactement ce qui se trouve dans
cette loi je ne prétends pas que ce soit
parfait mais je crois que cela
représente déjà
un assez gros effort de solidarité
nationale en faveur d'une catégorie de
Français qui a souffert dans sa chair et
dans son sang qui méritait cet effort
mais qui ne peut pas espérer
50 milliards par an pendant peut-être
15 ans peut-être plus d'ores et déjà
c'est un engagement de l'ordre de 750
milliards d'anciens francs en faveur des
rapatriés d'Algérie
et bien messieurs
une dernière question dans ce domaine et
nous passerons à la politique
du mortier nord-éclette ma question
précisément enquête peut être sur la
seconde partie vous avez évoqué à
Strasbourg monsieur le Président le
problème de la déconcentration de du
rôle des assemblées municipales ou
départementales et de la réforme des
finances locales vous n'avez pas parlé
de la réforme des régions du problème
des assemblées au suffrage universel
est-ce que cela veut dire que les la
réforme communale est devenue un
préalable de la réforme régionale
c'est en effet un peu une transition
la France est un vieux pays
et
je crois que
quand on veut le réformer
il faut d'abord partir des réalités de
ce qui existe
je crois qu'à l'heure actuelle
ce qui est le plus désagréable
ou ressenti comme le plus désagréable
à l'échelon local et régional
c'est une certaine emprise
administrative
qui fait que toutes les décisions
remontent à Paris
que tout le monde est soumis à une
tutelle qu'il juge insupportable et à
des contrôles a priori qu'il trouve
paralyse
c'est pourquoi
je considère
qu'en dehors
du problème de la régionalisation
donc comme pour tous les mots en Sion je
voudrais savoir exactement ce qu'on met
dedans
en dehors de ce problème il y a des
réformes qui s'imposent
si je prends les villes les communes
elles sont soumises à une tutelle
extrêmement étroite
elles sont soumises à un contrôle
financier a priori
qui retarde toute décision tout
entreprises
et souvent finit par l'interdit
je pense donc
qu'il convient d'abord de revoir ce
problème de la tutelle et du contre
je pense donc qu'il convient d'abord de
répartir mieux les charges et par
conséquent les ressources entre l'État
et les communes et qu'il y a une réforme
des finances locales qui s'imposent
je pense aussi d'ailleurs que des
problèmes du même mot du même ordre se
trouvent à l'échelle du département et
quand bien des cas le préfet comme
représentant de l'administration et le
Conseil général comme représentant de la
population serait en mesure l'un avec
l'autre de prendre de très nombreuses
décisions dans un grand nombre de
domaines alors qu'à l'heure actuelle là
aussi ils sont soumis à l'intervention
des bureaux parisiens
libérer
nos villes nos départements nos régions
aussi de tout ce qu'il y a d'excessives
dans cette tutelle de tout ce qu'il y a
d'écrasons dans cette dans cette emprise
administrative voilà la tâche la plus
importante à mes yeux à l'heure actuelle
je sais d'ailleurs que le premier
ministre a fait entreprendre des études
dans tous ces domaines mais je sais
aussi et je lui dis que l'heure des
études doit maintenant céder la place à
l'heure de l'action
il faut
que l'État se réforme lui-même
il faut que nous nous dégagions
d'une emprise administrative qui est
devenue écrasante au fur et à mesure que
les responsabilités de l'État se sont
étendues et il faut que nous créons
véritablement l'habitude de la
démocratie locale voilà à mes yeux ce
qu'il y a de plus important pour l'année
où les deux années qui viennent et ce
que nous entreprendrons je l'espère dès
la rentrée
monsieur le Président de la République
je vous demande pardon
mais puisque vous avez le micro garder
le Virieu
ORTF information première monsieur le
Président de la République supposons que
l'opposition se structure comme vous
l'avez souhaité à Strasbourg supposons
qu'elle se structure au point de devenir
majoritaire lors des élections
législatives de 1973 pourriez-vous
envisager de choisir un premier ministre
ailleurs que dans la majorité qui vous a
soutenu au cours de la dernière élection
présidentielle
monsieur le fait pas des plans sur la
comète
d'abord il n'y a pas qu'une opposition
il y en a pour l'instant plusieurs il y
en a qui sont structurés il y en a
d'autres qui ne le sont pas ça n'est pas
à moi à leur donner la recette pour se
structurer je ne suis pas conseil en
structuration d'opposition
je ne suis pas d'autre part à la veille
d'élection législatives
pour l'instant j'ai été élu par la
majorité des français
j'ai choisi un premier ministre et on a
fait un gouvernement à l'image de la
majorité qui m'avait élue si la
situation se transformait si la
situation devait devenir réellement
différente et bien alors j'aviserai la
Constitution me fournit d'ailleurs
fournit au chef de l'État plusieurs
mode de sortie de ces difficultés on
peut imaginer en effet de prendre un
premier ministre
en dehors de la majorité antérieure ou
sur les bords de cette majorité ou dans
la partie de cette majorité qui mon dieu
a un œil dedans et un dehors on peut
imaginer aussi de dissoudre cette
assemblée on peut imaginer bien des
choses nous avons une constitution que
beaucoup trouvent bâtarde et qui est en
réalité très souple et qui laisse au
chef de l'État beaucoup de possibilités
pour sortir des crises pour l'instant si
vous le permettez il n'y a pas de crise
en vue donc j'essaierai de dormir
tranquille et d'oublier votre question
monsieur Ferniot
jean-ferriot RTL France Soir monsieur le
Président de la République vous avez été
premier ministre pendant 6 ans vous êtes
président depuis une année vous avez pu
apprécier les différences entre ces deux
fonctions
pouvez-vous à offrir de cette expérience
nous dire quelle est la date normale
convenable moyenne de durée d'un Premier
ministre
je ne suis pas tout à fait sûr
autre question soit très convenable
je ne suis pas tout à fait sûr d'autre
part de pouvoir y donner une réponse
car là aussi je suis pris entre la
continuité et l'ouverture
la continuité ça serait de garder le
même Premier ministre pendant 6 ans et
demi
comme l'a fait le général de Gaulle en
ce qui me concerne l'ouverture
ça serait comme certains le souhaitent
d'en changer tous les six mois de façon
à nous redonner cette vie politique
active comme on dit n'est ce pas qui
faisait la joie des commentateurs
je tâcherai de trouver un moyen terme
monsieur Bassi
pierre Rouanet le Nouvel Observateur
monsieur le Président je voulais me
permettre de solliciter une réponse un
peu personnelle est-ce que vous êtes au
bout d'un an comptant du gouvernement
que vous avez choisi
comment pourrais-je en être mécontent
Europe numéro 1 il y a un an monsieur le
Président vous avez été élu par une
majorité de Français de Français qui
avait vu en vous à la fois l'homme de
la continuité et l'homme de l'ouverture
un an à passer n'avez-vous pas le
sentiment que dans cette majorité
nationale votre majorité il y a quelques
remous et je dirais même de la déception
certains certaines consultations
électorales nous l'ont démontrées et ne
croyez-vous pas que cette déception
serait dû au fait qu'il n'y a pas eu à
cette changement
j'ai quelques échos
de ce que vous dites
en vous écoutant ou en vous lisant
notamment
[Musique]
il m'apparaît quelquefois
que
si dans la majorité il y a des
mécontentements c'est plutôt parce qu'on
trouve qu'il y a eu trop de changements
d'autres peut-être trouvent le contraire
j'en reviens à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure
à Monsieur ferngne
la vie politique
prend évidemment un beaucoup de sel à
partir du moment où il y a des crises
mais que voulez-vous
l'intérêt national n'est pas qu'il y ait
des cris
à partir du moment où
le gouvernement que j'ai nommé
dispose à la major à l'Assemblée
nationale d'une majorité très large
il n'y a aucun espoir qu'il soit
renversé
dès lors comme l'a dit un commentateur
avisé
l'assemblée se consacre fort bien à son
travail législatif
mais
renonce quelque peu à son rôle politique
ce qui veut dire renonce à mettre en
cause la responsabilité du gouvernement
dès lors aussi on cherche où il pourrait
y avoir
motif de crise
ça peut se trouver à l'intérieur de la
majorité où il y a toujours des
divergences dans toutes les majorités et
surtout quand elles sont nombreuses ça
peut se trouver entre le chef de l'État
et son premier ministre
et bien rassurez-vous il n'y a pas de
risque de crise entre le chef de l'État
et son premier mythe
et quand à la majorité dans la mesure
même où elle est très nombreuse comment
y aurait-il pas divergence d'opinions
d'autant plus qu'elles s'exprime avec la
plus entière liberté puisque ça n'a pas
de conséquence
mais croyez le bien s'il y avait péril
et bien cette majorité se ressoudrait
j'en suis convaincu
Serge maffaire de François il y a eu il
y a eu dimanche une élection à Nancy
est-ce que cette élection vous a fait
faire quelques réflexions
il était une fois un député de
Meurthe-et-Moselle qui s'appelait
Souchal
je tiens à dire que j'ai pour lui estimé
amitié bien qu'il m'est donné quelques
soucis quand j'étais Premier ministre
un jour
pour protester contre une décision
gouvernementale qui les ai paraît-il les
intérêts de Nancy il a des missions
et il a été battu
c'était dans la logique
car lorsque des électeurs veulent
manifester leur mécontentement au
gouvernement et bien ils choisissent
plutôt un candidat opposant plutôt qu'un
candidat de la majorité fut-il
contestataire
et d'ailleurs depuis 1886 en France tous
les députés qui ont été démystes qui ont
démissionné qui sont représentés ont été
battus
alors il y a Nancy
qui est une grande et admirable ville et
qui son orgueillit d'être la capitale
traditionnelle de la Lorraine
et il s'est trouvé qu'il y a bien des
années un gouvernement
a décidé de faire de messe le chef-lieu
de la région de ce jour-là une plaie a
été ouverte qui ne s'est jamais tout à
fait refermé et au fur et à mesure que
les années passées au fur et à mesure
que les attributions des régions ont été
augmentées que des services étaient
créés à Metz et quelquefois même
quittaient Nancy pour Metz l'irritation
grandissait chez les nycéens et la plaie
s'infectait il y en a eu des
démonstrations à plusieurs reprises
prenez le référendum du 27 avril 1969
Nancy qui est une ville fondamentalement
gaulliste à voter contre au référendum
pourquoi parce que c'était un référendum
sur la régionalisation et que pour Nancy
régionalisation ça veut dire primauté de
messe
après quoi on a essayé
la concertation
et le maire de Nancy le maire de Metz
avec les autorités administratives on
discuté pour répartir les attributions
et sont arrivés à un accord et devant
cet accord les nan céens se sont
révoltés estimant que leur mère avait
capituler devant le maire de Nancy de
Metz
et il y a eu crise municipale
élections municipale et à cette élection
municipale il y avait une liste conduite
par Monsieur Souchal et dont je vous
prie d'observer qu'elle a obtenu
exactement le même pourcentage de voix
qu'elle a obtenu également monsieur
Souchal lui-même à la dernière élection
législative alors vous le voyez tout
cela n'est pas tellement nouveau
j'ai répondu un peu tout à l'heure en ce
qui concerne les réflexions que me fait
faire cette élection
concernant le rôle des collectivités
locales et leur rapport avec les
administrations centrales
pour le reste
et bien je ne vois pas la politique de
la France ni celle de Nancy en forme de
bande dessinée
et je ne crois pas qu'on soit amené à
débattiser la place Stanislas
monsieur le Président Noël copain de la
Croix lorsque vous étiez Premier
ministre vous avez répété à plusieurs
reprises que le régime de la Cinquième
République était un régime mis
parlementaire mi-présidentiel et vous
vous réjouissiez de ce dosage de cet
équilibre estimez-vous que ce dosage
s'est équilibre soit demeuré si oui vous
en réjouissez-vous encore et sinon le
déplorez-vous
je n'ai pas changé
je crois en effet que notre Constitution
est à mi-chemin d'un régime proprement
présidentiel et d'un régime proprement
parlementaire je crois que cet équilibre
d'ailleurs difficile
à le mérite de donner à notre
au fonctionnement notre système
politique à la fois les possibilités de
la fermeté de la durée et en même temps
la souplesse
j'ai entendu ici comme Premier ministre
le général de Gaulle dire qu'il n'y
avait pas de hiérarchie
je peux bien dire comme président de la
République qu'il n'y a pas de hiérarchie
mais au total je crois que le système
n'est pas mauvais
de la République Bernard Lefort Paris
dans moins de 9 mois maintenant il y
aura des élections municipales
l'élection partielle de Nancy
législative celle-là dont nous voulons
nous parler à donner des espérances à
certains croyez-vous que l'on puisse
attribuer la valeur d'un test national
aux prochaines élections municipales
nous avons tous en nous des calculs que
nous appelons espérance à des Platon
je ne crois pas
que les élections municipales doivent
être considérées comme un test national
quand on vote dans les élections
municipales on vote avant tout pour
avoir une bonne administration de sa
cité
et en particulier dans la plupart de nos
communes et de nos villes on vote pour
un maire et pour un bon maire
et bien il arrive
qu'il y a des bons mères
qui se disent sans triste par exemple
et
qu'ils peuvent être élus ou réélu parce
qu'ils sont de bons mais ça ne veut pas
dire que la nation adhère aux options
politiques d'ailleurs indéfinissable du
centrisme
il arrive qu'il y a de bons mères
qui sont socialistes et ben ils peuvent
être réels en tant que bon mais
et non pas spécialement parce que la
population est à vide de nationalisation
il peut arriver aussi il arrive qui est
de bons mères qui soit de la majorité
qui soit réélu comme bon mais et non pas
parce qu'ils sont de la majorité et il
arrive enfin que dans certains endroits
et en particulier à Paris et dans la
région parisienne forcément l'élection
municipale prenne un tour plus politique
et qu'elle mène à un affrontement entre
des formations qui s'opposent et là ça
prend en effet une valeur plus politique
et moins spécifiquement municipal ou
administratives mais au total en ce qui
me concerne je ne considère pas que les
élections municipales doivent être
considérées du doivent être regardés
comme des élections politiques
Gérard Badel le Parisien Libéré monsieur
le Président vous avez souligné avec
beaucoup de force la nécessité de
desserrer l'emprise administrative sur
les collectivités locales et régionales
or il y a précisément une ville
française à laquelle vous venez faire
allusion c'est notre capital qui
supporte beaucoup plus que les autres
une tutelle administrative les élus
parisiens de la majorité demandent
actuellement que Paris soit doté d'une
autonomie de gestion comparable aux
autres villes de France est-ce que vous
souhaitez que les Parisiens puissent
élir un maire un bon maire en tout cas
un vrai maire
je crois souhaitable
d'alléger et de simplifier les modalités
de la tutelle sur l'administration
parisienne je crois qu'à Paris comme
ailleurs les élus municipaux le Conseil
de Paris doivent avoir plus de liberté
et plus de possibilités d'action
quant aux problèmes du maire de Paris
c'est une autre affaire
Paris n'est pas seulement Paris c'est
aussi la capitale de la France et par
conséquent cela pose pour le
gouvernement et pour l'État une question
de toute première importance c'est qu'on
ne peut pas résoudre à mon avis aussi
simplement que pour toute autre ville de
France
combat plusieurs incidences survenus
récemment sanctions prises contre des
réalisateurs d'une émission de variété
pression exercée par une catégorie
sociaux professionnelle contre la
diffusion d'une séquence télévisée
conflit à propos du film cadets de
Saumur démission de réalisateur de
panoramas traduisent un malaise à la
télévision et la relativité ou la
fragilité de ce qui les convenu
d'appeler la libéralisation de l'ORTF
quel est votre sentiment à ce sujet en
tant que premier téléspectateur de
France et en tant que président quel
bilan faites-vous d'une année de
télévision ces incidents vous
paraissent-ils normaux si vous les
déplorez comment envisagez-vous qu'il ne
se renouvelle plus quelle garantie
pourrait offrir à cet égard le prochain
statut de l'ORTF
contrairement à ce que vous croyez je
suis très loin d'être le premier
télé-spectateur de France
d'abord parce que mes horaires de
travail me permettent très difficilement
de regarder la télévision
et puis d'une façon générale et cela
depuis bien des années je tiens à
ménager mon équilibre nerveux
néanmoins
je m'intéresse à la télévision
croyez le bien
et depuis que je m'y intéresse je
n'entends parler que d'incident
rien ne va jamais à la télévision
il y avait un ministre de l'information
on disait que c'était un dictateur
et que il imposait
au journaliste de la télévision
des règles et une tutelle inadmissible
le Premier ministre a jugé
utile de supprimer ce ministre
l'information
il paraît si je vous crois que c'est
pareil
faut-il en conclure n'est-ce pas que
l'auto-gestion est aussi
néfaste et aussi dictatorial que la
gestion ministérielle
en tout cas nous n'avons jamais trouvé
en France parfaitement l'équilibre de
notre information
c'est peut-être dû au gouvernement c'est
peut-être dû aussi aux journalistes
pour moi
je vous dirai
que je considère que l'information sous
toutes ses formes alors
doit être libre
doit être indépendant doit être
impartial
et je compte d'ailleurs
que le rapport que Monsieur paille a
déposé au nom de sa commission nous
permettra de trouver des formules sinon
idéales tout au moins meilleure
peut-être que celle que nous avons eu
jusqu'ici
mais j'ajoute autre chose
à l'usage en particulier de ceux qui
sont ici et qui travaillent à l'ERT
être journaliste à l'ORTF ça n'est pas
la même chose que d'être journaliste
ailleurs
l'ORTF qu'on le veuille ou non c'est la
voix de la France
c'est considéré comme tel à l'étranger
et c'est considéré comme tel par le
public
qui quand on lui dit quelque chose
quand on lui fait remarquer quelque
chose répond mais c'est pas vrai ils
l'ont dit à la télé
ils l'ont dit à la télé et par
conséquent ceux qui parlent à la
télévision ou à France Inter ils parlent
un peu au nom de la France et il y a une
certaine hauteur de ton qui est la chose
que pour ma part je leur demande et ceux
qui m'ont suivi depuis que je suis au
gouvernement se rappelleront que dès
1962 je crois j'ai réuni les
journalistes et les représentants de
l'ORTF et que je leur ai dit exactement
la même chose je ne vous demande pas de
faire l'éloge du gouvernement je ne vous
demande pas de faire parler à tout
propos les ministres il y a d'ailleurs
je le sais bien rien de plus ennuyeux
pour les téléspectateurs ce que je vous
demande c'est de vous rappeler que quand
vous parlez vous ne parlez pas quand
votre nom et que vous le vouliez ou non
vous engagez la France et qui a une
certaine hauteur de ton et de penser qui
vous est réclamé c'est très difficile
c'est plus difficile que d'être ailleurs
je le reconnais
France Inter
monsieur le président
monsieur le Président vous allez parler
tout à l'heure du contenu des mots en
Sion qu'y a-t-il pour vous en 1968 en
1970 pardon dans le mot participation
crois que je l'ai dit à Strasbourg je
crois que je l'ai dit longuement dans ma
dernière conférence de presse
précisément je voudrais
ne pas être amené à me répéter
éternellement et dire simplement que
pour moi ce que j'appelle la
participation dans tous les domaines
c'est en fin de compte le respect de la
dignité de l'homme et la reconnaissance
de son droit aux responsabilités alors
on peut tirer de ça n'importe quoi tout
est le reste le pire et le meilleur cela
dépend des hommes mais ce qui a de bien
certains c'est que si on ne veut pas
reconnaître ce besoin ce besoin qui est
dans tous les hommes et bien forcément
et tôt ou tard notre société cracra
vous voyez Radio Monte
en Sion élection aux prochaines
élections municipales monsieur le
Président il y aura de nouveaux
électeurs de moins de 21 ans pour la
première fois les gens qui auront
accompli leurs services militaire
voteront pensez-vous qu'il faille aller
plus loin et aller jusqu'au vote à 18 ou
à 19 ans
nous avons fait un premier pas en liant
le droit de vote à
l'accomplissement d'un certain devoir
national
et qui donne par conséquent droit à
participer au responsabilités
faut-il aller plus loin
je ne suis pas contre a priori
ça dépend aussi de ce que désire les
gens
si vraiment les Français les jeunes
Français désirent voter il est probable
que un jour ou l'autre et peut-être
bientôt on pourra leur donner le droit
de vote plutôt de toute manière il faut
bien qu'il y ait un moment où l'on a le
droit de vote et un moment où on n'est
pas ou on ne l'a pas encore alors là où
on met la barre n'importe pas tellement
quand nous avons dit que ceux qui
avaient fait leur service militaire
aurait le droit de vote c'était moins
parce qu'il ce n'était pas parce qu'ils
auraient moins de 21 ans c'est parce que
je le répète ayant accompli leurs
services ayant servi la nation et bien
ils avaient le droit de donner leur avis
sur la conduite de cette nation
André Albert leur vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure monsieur le Président de la
large majorité qui soutenait le
gouvernement cette majorité est
apparemment plus large que celle qui
vous a envoyé siéger à l'Elysée cette
constatation vous satisfait-elle
correspond-t-elle chez vous à un vœu ou
pour parler le langage de Platon à une
espérance
de toute manière elle est derrière moi
cette espérance
mais je ne vois aucun inconvénient à ce
que la majorité parlementaire soit plus
large que la majorité présidentielle ce
qui serait fâcheux c'est que cette
majorité parlementaire se rétrécit
suffisamment pour devenir une minorité
monsieur le Président je ne voudrais pas
vous poser une question
de bonne municipalités que ministres je
voudrais simplement revenir sur la
première question qui vous a été posée
et à laquelle me semble-t-il vous avez
donné une réponse ambigu du moins en ce
qui du moins me semble-t-il faut-il
comprendre de ce que vous avez dit que
si la politique actuelle était désavouée
clairement par le suffrage universel par
une opposition structurée vous
utiliseriez comme vous l'avez dit toute
la souplesse la Constitution pour
essayer d'empêcher l'expression de la
volonté de la nation du suffrage
universel
monsieur je vous satisferai en vous
disant qu'il y a probablement de bons
maires communistes
mais
quant à votre deuxième question
[Musique]
je n'ai point dit que j'utiliserai la
souplesse des institution pour aller
contre la volonté de chiffrage universel
je dis simplement que
en mettant les choses si je puis dire à
l'extrême
si un moment donné il y avait
contradiction évidente brutale entre
deux manifestations de la volonté
nationale l'une qui est l'élection du
Président de la République l'autre
l'élection d'une assemblée et bien
évidemment il faudrait que le pays soit
appelé à choisir et à dire à laquelle de
ces deux manifestations il donne la plus
grande importance
je suis le président de la République
pierre Charpy Paris presse tout à
l'heure vous avez renoncé à donner des
conseils à l'opposition pour se
structurer mais dimanche le samedi à
Strasbourg vous avez quand même décrit
une opposition structurée avec ces
cadres ça doctrine en souhaitant qu'elle
puisse devenir je crois l'aiguillon de
la majorité est-ce que à votre avis le
Parti communiste tel qu'il est
actuellement
peut jouer ce rôle dans une opposition
structurée
le Parti communiste est certainement
structuré si on a reproche à lui faire
ça n'est pas de manquer de structure le
Parti communiste a certainement une
idéologie je crois qu'il n'en fait pas
mystère et quant à être né Guyon il est
quelquefois piquant
monsieur le président
Jean Daniel de l'observateur
je voudrais vous demander quel est votre
réaction quand vous voyez chaque jour
dans les journaux non subversifs voire
gouvernementaux la liste de ce que les
nécessités dites du maintien de l'ordre
conduisent à
des répressions des détentions des
mauvais traitements au détriment de
citoyens innocents
tout dépend de la conception qu'on a de
l'innocence
je ne crois franchement pas
que nos prisons soient plein d'innocents
la liberté qui capitule et le pouvoir
qui se dégrade n'obtient point merci de
ces ennemis ces chateaux brillants qu'il
a dit
le président de la République si je peux
me permettre de faire la transition
entre la politique intérieure elle a
pris quelques étrangère
la France le 1er avril a proposé qu'il y
ait une consultation générale sur le sur
l'Indochine pensez-vous monsieur le
Président que trois mois après a étant
donné la situation qui règne là-bas que
cette proposition reste valable ou
est-ce qu'elle est enterrée
notre proposition reste valable et je
dirais le restera éternellement car
comme on voulait vous
qu'on puisse espérer mettre fin à la
guerre d'Indochine autrement quand
et autrement
qu'en parlant autour d'une table où
seront représentés tous ceux qui ont le
droit d'y être représenté
ce qui veut dire
non seulement les pays en guerre
mais tous ceux qui directement ou
indirectement et pour des raisons
diverses sont intéressés à la solution
du problème Indochine
et je le précise parce que ça veut dire
également vous ne comprenez bien la
Chine
vous avez dit en substance à Strasbourg
que l'Europe ne se fera quand on
développe pas les relations avec les
pays de l'Est européen et maintenant
monsieur le Président je crois que avec
l'écran transformation dans l'objet et
les héros et les marchés communs la
question est principale est la suivante
dans quelle mesure la France veut faire
sentir son influence pour que la
politique vous mener monsieur le
Président avec beaucoup de fermetés
soit poursuivi par les autres
partenaires du Marché Commun élargi
si je comprends bien votre question
monsieur
vous voulez
savoir si le développement du marché
commun peut aller de pair avec le
renforcement des liens entre l'Europe de
l'Ouest et l'Europe de l'Est
ce que j'ai dit à Strasbourg
c'est que précisément là et non
seulement mon souhait mais la condition
même pour que cette Europe de l'Ouest
puisse progresser sur la voie de son
unité car
si l'Europe de l'Ouest devait être un
bloc fermé sur elle-même
et tournant le dos à l'Europe de l'Est
non seulement aucun progrès n'aurait été
fait mais nous en reviendrions au pire
moment de la guerre froide et du rideau
de fer comme on disait à l'époque or
toute la politique de la France est pour
faire tomber ce rideau toute la
politique de la France et pour établir
entre l'Est et l'Ouest entre tous les
pays de l'Ouest et tous les pays de
l'Est le maximum de relations le maximum
de coopération le maximum d'entente dans
tous les domaines et c'est pourquoi
l'Europe ai-je dit ne se fera que dans
ces conditions parce que si elle ne
devait pas se faire dans ces conditions
la France refuserait de la faire
une compagnie des États-Unis en dehors
de cette conférence plus large dont vous
avez parlé monsieur le Président à votre
avis quelles sont les perspectives de la
conférence de Paris sur le Vietnam et
les perspectives de la paix en Indochine
en général après les déclarations du
président Nixon
il y a un point dont je me félicite
c'est de la domination de Monsieur David
brousse pour diriger la délégation
américaine à la conférence de Paris et
je souhaite que cette conférence de
Paris que la France a été heureuse
d'accueillir que cette conférence y
retrouve vie et par conséquent que cela
ouvre la voie ou les perspectives d'un
règlement négocié
ceci étant dit
il n'y a pas dans les déclarations du
président Nixon que des raisons de se
réjouir je ne peux pas le dissimuler et
je ne peux pas ne pas répéter ce que
j'ai d'ailleurs dit
au Congrès des États-Unis à savoir
qu'il ne lui aura de perspectives de
paix en Indochine que le jour où les
États-Unis auront pris de même et
volontairement la ferme résolution
d'évacuer l'Indochine
là et la base de tout et à partir de là
on peut espérer que toutes les
interventions et toutes les émissions de
toute espèce cesseront et que chacun de
ces malheureux états de l'Indochine
retrouvera la possibilité de la vie de
la paix de l'indépendance et je le
souhaite de la neutralité et puis ce que
tout le monde fait des appels si j'avais
en faire un et bien moi je dirais pitié
pour le peuple sudamien pitié pour le
peuple Nord vietnamien pitié pour le
peuple cambodgien pitié pour le peuple
là-haut pitié peut-être demain pour le
peuple thaï et qu'on cesse de faire de
ces malheureuses populations l'enjeu et
la victime de rivalité qui les dépassent
et qui même ne les concerne pas voilà la
politique de la France
monsieur le Président estimez-vous de la
politique du chancelier Brandt peut
faciliter la construction d'une Europe
quelle que vous la définition à
Strasbourg
si je croyais le contraire madame
les entretiens que j'aurais demain avec
le chancelier Brandt risquerait d'être
difficile
mais je crois profondément
que la politique de rapprochement avec
l'EST
car entreprise le chancelier Brand et
dans l'intérêt général de l'euro
de l'Europe de l'Ouest de l'Europe de
l'Est et de l'Europe tout entière je le
crois il va de soi que je lis partout
que la France redoute la puissance
économique allemande et bien entendu les
nations sont comme tout le monde et l'on
préfère avoir des voisins moins grands
que des voisins trop grands mais nous
nous inquiétons nullement de la
puissance économique allemande et je
dirais même que nous préférons que ça
soit la forme moderne de la puissance
allemande ce qui est important pour nous
c'est de faire que notre propre
puissance économique nous permettent de
tenir notre place dans cette Europe nous
permettent de faire face à cette
concurrence et la puissance économique
allemande doit être pour nous un
aiguillon et non pas une terreur
dans le cas où après de longues
négociations le gouvernement britannique
se trouverait dans l'impossibilité
d'accepter intégralement les mécanismes
financières du marché qu'on a
seriez-vous en faveur d'un compromis ou
estimez-vous que dans ce cas il serait
nécessaire d'écarter la candidature
britannique
c'est une question qui pèsera sur nous
pendant longtemps et pendant toute la
durée des négociations et si je vous
comprends bien il s'agit de savoir si on
peut avoir un pied dedans ou un pied
d'or maintenant je ne le crois pas je ne
le crois pas il faut être dedans où il
faut être dehors ceci étant dit même
quand on est dehors il peut y avoir des
possibilités d'accommodement mais nous
n'en sommes pas là la conversation
s'ouvre nous avons dit à la haie que
nous étions près à cette ouverture et
que nous étions prêts à participer
positivement en négociation ça sera
l'attitude du gouvernement français tout
au long de la négociation mais il ne
faut pas s'attendre à ce qu'il fasse
tous les pas en avant
le Premier ministre de la
Grande-Bretagne monsieur
qui croyait possible et désirable qui a
une
collaboration franco-anglaise entre les
forces nucléaires des deux pays pour la
défense ou pour la mettre à la
disposience disposition de la défense de
l'Europe je me suis renseigné il est
toujours de cet avis quel est le vôtre
tout est dans la manière sur walking
qu'il puisse y avoir des accords en
matière nucléaire entre la France et la
Grande-Bretagne c'est en effet possible
c'est même probablement souhaitables
mais il y a des limites qu'il ne faut
pas espérer nous faire franchir par cet
appât et en particulier on nous fera pas
rentrer dans l'OTAN
et lors de votre lors de votre
conférence de presse le 10 juillet vous
avez parlé de l'éventualité d'un retour
à l'embargo sélectif en ce qui concerne
Israël un an après et prenons
considération la présence soviétique au
Moyen-Orient qu'en est-il
monsieur
depuis un an en effet il se passe pas de
jour ni de semaine
ou
quelqu'un ne dise ou ne se demande si
notre politique en matière d'embargo se
modifie Vasse modifier c'est modifié
et les questionnaires et les
informations
sont infatigables ils me font penser à
ces gens
qui appellent éternellement le même
numéro de téléphone et qui ne sont pas
découragés parce que le disque leur
répond il n'y a pas d'abonnés au numéro
que vous avez demandé et bien monsieur
il n'y a pas d'abonnés au numéro que
vous avez demandé
de la rue de François
je vous permettrai cependant de poser
une question plus générale au sujet de
la situation créée en Méditerranée il
semble bien tout de même que depuis un
an la situation stratégique à
Méditerranée a été assez fortement
modifiée d'abord par la présence
considérée de force accrue soviétique en
Egypte mais également la France a fait
savoir qu'elle a une politique
méditerranéenne qui va suivre activement
que pouvez-vous nous dire là-dessus
monsieur le président
la politique méditerranéenne de la
France ne consiste pas à menacer la paix
en Méditerranée je peux vous le garantir
ce que nous appelons politique
méditerranéenne ça consiste à entretenir
des relations les meilleures possibles
les plus étroites possibles avec tous
nos voisins méditerranéens sans
exception et par priorité avec les plus
proches soit par la géographie soit par
l'histoire mais avec tous
quand à l'équilibre des forces dont vous
parlez
et dont il est en question et bien à nos
yeux il n'y a qu'une manière de rétablir
cet équilibre des forces c'est de faire
la paix une fois encore nous ne cessons
de le répéter il faut faire la paix au
Moyen-Orient
certains jours on espère et le lendemain
ont désespéré mais il faudra bien y
arriver faute de quoi effectivement
l'équilibre des forces ne cessera de se
dégrader et en particulier et quoi qui
fasse il ne cessera de se dégrader au
détriment d'Israël c'est pourquoi c'est
de l'intérêt d'Israël plus que de
personnes d'autres d'aboutir un
règlement de paix d'accepter un
règlement de paix et tous les efforts
que nous faisons sans grands succès
jusqu'ici en particulier au sein de la
Conférence des quatre tendent à ce but
faire la paix
monsieur le Président quelles sont à
votre avis les conditions indispensables
de parvenir à un tel règlement et quels
sont les chances d'y aboutir
les chances
je le répète mon opinion sur ce point
varie sans cesse peut-être en ce moment
sont-elles un peu meilleur qu'il y a un
mois ou deux
quant aux modalités du règlement je me
garderai bien de les donner il n'y a pas
de plan de règlement français et il ne
doit pas y avoir de plan de règlement
américain et il ne doit pas y avoir de
plantes règlement soviétique il faut
puisque eux seuls peuvent le faire que
les quatre présentent un plan de
règlement commun car seul un plan de
réglement commun pourra être accepté par
les uns et par les autres et tout plan
présenté isolément par une nation est
automatiquement suspect à l'une des
partisans présentes
mais sur les données générales vous
connaissez notre position elle résulte
de du vote du Conseil de sécurité de la
résolution du Conseil de sécurité il est
évident que les modalités sont très
importantes ces modalités nous sur ces
modalités nous avons notre opinion nous
la défendons au sein de la concertation
A4 bien entendu mais nous préférons le
pas la rendre public je le répète nous
ne cherchons pas dans cette affaire un
succès de prestige nous cherchons
purement et simplement à rétablir la
paix je le dis une fois de plus mais
c'est un mot qu'on le répète jamais
assez dans le monde actuel de la rue de
François monsieur le Président vous avez
fait allusion tout à l'heure aux
difficultés du système monétaire
international la France contre elle
prendre des initiatives pour contribuer
à les résorber
la difficulté
fondamentale du système monétaire
international vient de ce que dans la
pratique le dollar est devenu étalon
et de ce que ce dollar n'a pas une
valeur stable du fait d'une certaine
inflation américaine et d'un certain
déséquilibre de la balance des paiements
américains
tout ça est évident tout ça est connu
à partir de ce moment-là que
pouvons-nous faire
il est pas question
bien entendu
de faire ce qu'on appelle la guerre
au-delà
car
une crise du dollar serait une
catastrophe pour tous les pays
d'économie libérale
ce qu'il faut
c'est d'une part que le gouvernement
américain prenne toutes les mesures
nécessaires pour rétablir
les bases de sa position
pourrait pour rendre le dollar
réellement stable est-ce qu'il faut
d'autre part c'est que les nations
européennes a commencé par la France
essaie ensemble
de créer non pas une monnaie unique nous
en sommes loin
mais un ensemble monétaire une certaine
union monétaire qui fasse
que les pays européens puissent en
quelque sorte équilibrées par leur masse
économique puisse équilibrer le dollar
nous avons en ce sens déposé un certain
nombre de propositions vous le savez
auprès de nos partenaires on a commencé
cela veut dire que
nous devons nous entendre entre nous que
lorsque l'un d'entre nous pour une
raison pour une autre
se trouve en difficulté il faut que ce
soit
nos partenaires de la communauté
auxquels ils demandent par priorité une
aide
cela veut dire qu'il faut éviter que les
marges de fluctuation entre les monnaies
européennes puissent s'accroître
même si
à l'échelle internationale
on cherche
à favoriser un certain accroissement des
marges entre les monnaies le fait que
les nations européennes refuseraient
cette formule pour ce qui les concerne
serait déjà une ordonnerait une grande
force et une certaine unité
cela veut dire qu'on peut imaginer des
plans à moyen terme d'aide mutuelles de
concertation mutuelle d'harmonisation de
des politiques monétaires liées
d'ailleurs obligatoirement à une
certaine harmonisation des politiques
économiques
il y a un long chemin à parcourir un
très long chemin pourquoi s'étonner de
ce que le chemin soit long il s'est
passé 40 ans entre la fondation du sol
ferraille c'est-à-dire de l'unité
douanière allemande et l'apparition du
marc comme monnaie unique et encore
après cela s'est-il passé
60 ans avant que la banque la banque
d'émission allemande et le monopole de
l'émission du marc vous voyez que nous
avons devant nous pas mal de décennies
comme dirait un de vos confrères mais je
pense que nous pouvons aller plus vite
simplement ne nous fixons pas de dates
trop rapprochées faisons nos pas l'un
après l'autre progressons chaque jour
chaque semaine et chaque année c'est le
seul moyen de faire quelque chose plutôt
que de dresser des plans sur la comète
je suis pour ma part persuadé que
l'Europe se fait en marchant
contenu de tous les problèmes européens
évoqués quels sont d'après vous monsieur
le Président les chances actuellement
d'une coopération dans le domaine
politique entre les pays européens à
l'ouest
tout dépend de ce qu'on appelle une
coopération politique
je suis partisan et nous l'avons
d'ailleurs accepté que les gouvernements
se rencontrent que les mises à faire
étrangères se rencontrent et qu'il se
rend compte pour parler non pas de leurs
problèmes internes mais de la politique
générale et des problèmes de politique
générale et concours de ces rencontres
non seulement ils s'informent mais se
consultent et que chaque fois que c'est
possible on cherche à harmoniser les
positions voir à les unifier
quand ta pensée qui puisse y avoir
demain une politique européenne il y
aura une politique européenne le jour où
il y aura à tout le mois une
confédération européenne et pour ma part
je crois possible et souhaitable de
parvenir à une confédération européenne
mais je crois que le meilleur moyen de
la tuer c'est de vouloir brûler les
étapes à l'heure actuelle que
voyons-nous nous voyons la République
fédérale préoccupé avant tout des
problèmes avec l'EST et des problèmes
qui lui viennent de sa de la division
allemande nous voyons la Grande-Bretagne
qui veut entrer dans la communauté mais
qui en même temps garde des relations
particulières avec les États-Unis qui ne
sont pas en Europe et nous rappelle tous
les intérêts qu'elle possède dans le
monde entier et notamment dans le
commonwells la France elle-même a des
intérêts un peu partout dans le monde et
des attitudes qui ne sont pas forcément
les mêmes que celles de ses partenaires
européens par conséquent vouloir du jour
au lendemain dire qu'il y aura une union
politique c'est purement illusoire il
n'y a aucune chance à l'heure actuelle
que nous ayons la même politique le
problème de la coopération c'est
précisément de se rencontrer de discuter
des s'informer de se rapprocher pour
aboutir un jour à cette politique unique
et le jour en effet où on aurait une
confédération européenne ou quelque
chose qui ressemblerait le jour où on
aurait une union politique européenne à
coup sûr le repérer d'un grand poids
dans le monde mais le passé est là qui
est lourd la géographie est là qu'on ne
peut pas non plus éliminer et qui n'a
pas fait de l'Europe une nation unie au
cours des siècles il faut donc beaucoup
de patience mais
il faut aussi la foi
patience et foi c'est ma devise si vous
voulez
compte tenu de la présence à Paris de la
conférence permet de revenir au problème
de l'Indochine compte tenu de la
présence à Paris de la conférence de
americano vietnamienne compte tenu du
fait que la France a aussi des relations
et à peu près le seul pays à avoir des
relations avec tous les intéressés
pouvez-vous nous dire quelle est
actuellement son rôle
puisqu'elle pourrait jouer semble-t-il
un rôle privilégié entre les différentes
parties
son rôle à l'heure actuelle
consiste d'abord comme vous l'avez dit
entretenir des relations avec tout le
monde
son rôle consiste ensuite à essayer par
toute où elle le peut de donner des
conseils et de se faire entendre son
rôle consiste enfin à essayer par toute
où elle le peut de protéger les vies et
les intérêts notamment culturels nous le
faisons par priorité pour les intérêts
français mais nous le faisons partout où
nous pouvons pour les intérêts des
autres
et puis et puis et bien nous donnons
Paris pour la conférence entre les
États-Unis et le Nord Vietnam et le Sud
Vietnam et puis nous suggérons que je
lance réunit à tous et que l'on parle
tout cela vous me direz n'est pas
d'unification immédiate c'est exact et
nous ne pouvons que le déplorer mais
tout cela finira bien par peser dans la
balance parce que c'est la voie du bon
sens et que tout de même s'agissant de
la France et de l'Indochine c'est aussi
un peu la voix du cœur voilà messieurs
si vous permettez encore une question et
puis je crois que j'aurais fait ce que
vous attendiez de moi
et tout est pas la voix du Canada
monsieur le Président vous avez dit au
sujet de l'Indochine tout à l'heure que
le rôle de la France était précisément
d'entretenir des relations avec tout le
monde et c'est à dire que la France
compte continuer d'entretenir des
relations avec le gouvernement du prince
Yannick
nous entretenons des relations avec le
prince
alors la dernière messieurs monsieur le
Président je voudrais pour la dernière
question revenir sur l'affaire du
Moyen-Orient qui est sans nul doute la
question actuellement la plus grave et
qui pour des questions des raisons
diverses que nous toucher aussi
directement
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que votre
gouvernement s'employait à maintenir ou
du moins à essayer d'obtenir la paix
mais la paix vous l'avez dit vous-même
c'est quelque chose de dur à obtenir
toutes les parties y sont intéressées
toutes les parties sont responsables le
président Nixon a déclaré cette nuit que
le déséquilibre des forces au
Moyen-Orient s'opérant au détriment
d'Israël nous conduirait obligatoirement
à une guerre
monsieur moriche Schuman a différentes
reprises à déclaré que la position du
gouvernement français
pouvait évoluer suivant les
circonstances est-ce que vous ne pensez
pas vous aussi que le fait de voir
l'équilibre
se détériorer au détriment d'Israël
c'est-à-dire les menaces se préciser
est-ce que vous pensez pas que cela
aussi pourrait être un événement grave
pouvant conduire non pas à la paix mais
au contraire à une extension du conflit
c'est possible en effet et c'est
pourquoi il est probablement préférable
plutôt que d'être là à peser les armes
de chaque camp et à mesurer l'équilibre
il est probablement préférable de faire
pression pour aboutir à la paix car si
la politique qui veut ou qui affirme
avoir pour objectif la paix consiste
simplement à fournir un peu plus d'armes
à l'un puis un peu plus d'armes à
l'autre pour que les deux plateaux de la
balance soit égaux qu'il soit égaux ou
qu'il y ait déséquilibres le risque est
grave et grave pour tout le monde
donc je pense
que plus que jamais la paix et la paix
rapide et nécessaire et je le répète je
pense plus que jamais que le temps
travaille contre Israël et que rien ne
serait plus grave non seulement pour
Israël mais pour le monde entier que de
transformer un conflit qui à l'heure
actuelle est certes déplorable mais du
moins est localisé entre un conflit
alors généralisé entre deux très grandes
puissances pour le coup ce serait un
désastre mondial
mais
ça ne dépend pas de nous malheureusement
que de ramener tout le monde à la
conception dont je parle c'est à dire à
la nécessité d'une paix négociée rapide
mesdames et messieurs je crois vraiment
et la le fait que les dernières
questions posées soient revenues sur des
sujets déjà traités je crois vraiment
mettre prêté à vos questions très
librement et que tous les sujets
possibles ont pu être abordés je vous
remercie infiniment de votre attention
et je vous donne rendez-vous à la
prochaine fois
[Musique]